Bien, en esta ocasión vamos a empezar con
una línea, así que déjame poner primero
aquí la ecuación de esta línea.
Voy a decir que "y" es igual a "x" más 3
y lo que quiero hacer ahora es graficar todos
los puntos que satisfagan esta ecuación o
dicho de otra manera, todos los pares "x", "y"
que cumplan esta ecuación y bueno,
¿qué me sale al graficar esta ecuación?
Pues una línea recta, así que
este va a ser mi eje de las "y",
este va a ser mi eje de las "x"
y voy a poner esta línea recta aquí,
lo primero que hay que fijarnos
es en la ordenada al origen o la intersección,
con el eje de las "y", que es 3,
por lo tanto vamos a caminar 3 hacia arriba,
para poner aquí que esta recta
intersecta en 3 al eje de las "y",
1, 2, 3...
aquí tengo la intersección con el eje de las "y"
en "y" igual a 3, es decir que cuando "x" vale 0,
"y" vale 3
y después tengo una pendiente de 1,
es decir que por cada 1 que avanzo, debo de subir 1,
por lo tanto, mi recta se ve más o menos así y
esta es la gráfica de esta recta,
ojo, quiero volver a repetirlo, esta línea recta representa
esta ecuación, debido a que todos los puntos
de esta línea recta son pares ordenados de
la forma "x", "y" que satisfacen esta ecuación,
por ejemplo, si pensamos en "x" igual a 5,
¿qué es lo que está pasando en "x" igual a 5?
Voy a tener aquí a "x" igual a 5 y si yo
lo meto en esta ecuación, me voy a dar cuenta
que la solución es 8, 5 más 3 es 8, por
lo tanto el 5, 8 existe en esta línea recta,
está situado en esta línea recta, es decir,
que cada uno de los puntos de esta línea recta,
es una solución a esta ecuación o
dicho de otra manera, esta línea recta es
el conjunto de todas las soluciones
que satisfacen esta ecuación.
¿pero qué pasa ahora si me tomo otra ecuación?
"y" es igual a "-x" más 3, la quiero graficar
en este mismo plano cartesiano,
pues lo primero que hay que fijarnos es en su ordenada al origen o en la intersección con el eje de las "y"
la cual también es 3 y la pendiente es -1,
por lo tanto es exactamente igual a la
recta que estoy dibujando justo ahorita, porque
cuando yo avanzo 1, realmente lo que tengo
que hacer es bajar 1 y si yo avanzo una cierta
cantidad para seguir en esa línea recta
tengo que bajar la misma cantidad.
Esta es la representación de esta ecuación,
"y" es igual a "-x" más 3,
es decir, que el conjunto de todos los puntos que están
en esta recta de morado, son la representación
gráfica de esta ecuación que tengo aquí arriba,
esta ecuación de morado.
Ahora bien, lo que realmente quiero preguntar
en este video, es si existe una solución en común,
dicho de otra manera, lo que voy
a buscar es una solución que cumpla estas
dos ecuaciones simultáneamente y bueno,
para eso lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
esta ecuación de amarillo está representada
por esta recta de amarillo,
mientras que esta ecuación de morado,
está representada por esta recta de morado.
Y cuando hablo de una solución que cumpla
estas dos ecuaciones simultáneamente,
otra forma de decir lo mismo
que me estoy preguntando,
es si existe un punto que esté en la intersección
de estas dos gráficas que tengo aquí abajo
o dicho de otra manera,
un punto que esté en ambas gráficas.
Y bueno, en este caso está muy sencillo,
ya lo tenemos, es el punto 0, 3.
Este punto es la solución que cumple ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente.
Fíjate bien, si yo pongo 0 en lugar de "x"
en estas ecuaciones, me quedaría 0 más 3,
esto es igual a 3, y en la otra ecuación
me quedaría "y" es igual a -0 más 3,
lo cual también es 3.
Este punto cumple ambas ecuaciones
y realmente lo que hicimos de una manera gráfica
fue resolver un sistema de ecuaciones, esto es
muy importante porque me tomé dos ecuaciones
simultáneamente,
la ecuación "y" es igual a "x" más 3...
déjame ponerla aquí...
"y" es igual a "x" más 3
y también me tomé
la ecuación "y" es igual a "-x" más 3.
Esta primera ecuación representa una línea
recta en el plano cartesiano,
esta segunda ecuación representa otra línea recta en el plano cartesiano y cuando yo me pregunto
acerca de un punto o una solución que satisfaga
ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente,
realmente lo que me estoy preguntando es en el punto
en la intersección de estas dos gráficas,
de estas dos rectas.
Cuando resuelvo un sistema de ecuaciones de
una manera gráfica, en lo que me estoy fijando
es en el punto de intersección y bueno,
en los videos siguientes, vas a darte cuenta
que hay varias formas de resolver un sistema
de ecuaciones, sin embargo,
en este video quiero analizar con mucho cuidado la forma gráfica de resolver un sistema de ecuaciones.
Y para esto mejor vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Recuerda, lo que estamos buscando es el punto
de intersección entre ambas rectas,
así que déjame tomarme la siguiente recta,
"y" es igual a "3x" menos 6
y bueno, como quiero crear un sistema de ecuaciones, me voy a tomar otra recta,
la recta "y" es igual a "-x" más 6,
así que bueno, como quiero resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones por el método gráfico,
lo que vamos a hacer es la gráfica de ambas rectas,
por lo tanto, déjame tomarme aquí mi eje de las "y", déjame tomarme por acá mi eje de las "x",
estoy haciendo mi plano cartesiano y dice,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 y 10...
y para acá,
y 1, 2, 3...
de hecho pude haber tomado cualquier papel
de gráfica, copiarlo y pegarlo, pero bueno,
ya lo estamos construyendo a mano, así que
vamos a fijarnos en la primera ecuación,
la primera ecuación tiene como
ordenada al origen a -6,
la intersección con el eje de las "y" es -6
y tiene una pendiente de 3,
esto quiere decir que cada vez
que caminamos 1 a la derecha,
hay que subir 3, 1 a la derecha,
subimos 3...
estamos justo...
1, 2, 3...
sí, estamos justo aquí.
Cada vez que caminamos 1 a la derecha,
subimos 3, cuando avanzamos 1, levantamos 3,
y ya tenemos esta ecuación graficada
en este plano cartesiano
con esta línea recta que tengo aquí,
"y" es igual a "3x" menos 6 se ve de
la siguiente manera, más o menos así, perfecto.
Ya que tengo la primera, ahora vamos a checar
qué pasa con la segunda.
"y" es igual a "-x" más 6, por lo tanto mi
ordenada al origen o mi intersección
con el eje de las "y" es 6
y después tengo una pendiente de -1,
cuando yo avanzo 1 a la derecha,
bajo 1,
cuando yo avanzo 1 a la derecha, vuelvo a bajar 1, cuando yo avanzo 1 a la derecha,
vuelvo a bajar 1, avanzo y bajo, avanzo y
bajo y de hecho date cuenta que intersectamos
al eje de las "x", justo aquí, en el valor de 6,
-6 más 6 me da 0,
entonces en el valor de 6
vamos a intersectar al eje de las "x".
Y perfecto,
ya tengo mis dos rectas graficadas,
ahora lo que quiero es fijarme en cual es
la intersección de estas dos rectas,
para encontrar aquel punto que satisfaga ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente,
la solución que satisfaga ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente.
Y bueno, si te das cuenta es más o menos
este punto de aquí,
que tal vez no se vea tan exacto,
precisamente porque lo hice a mano,
pero más o menos es este punto de aquí
que si te das cuenta es el 3 en "x"...
1, 2, 3 en "x"...
y 1, 2, 3 en "y",
de hecho es estos dos puntos,
estos dos puntos son el mismo punto
y es la intersección de ambas rectas, el punto 3, 3.
Y bueno, espero no haberme equivocado porque
todo esto lo estoy haciendo a mano,
sin embargo vamos a rectificarlo,
¿y cómo lo rectificamos?
Pues vamos a poner a "x" con el valor de 3
en estas ecuaciones y vamos a ver si obtenemos
el valor de 3 en "y" en estas ecuaciones,
es decir,
3 en "y", tiene que ser igual
a 3 veces "x", pero "x" vale 3
menos 6 y ésta checa,
3 por 3 = 9 menos 6 es 3,
¿y la siguiente qué me quedaría?
Bueno, "y" vale 3 y "x" vale 3 también,
3 es igual a -3 más 6
lo cual también es correcto,
-3 más 6 es 3 positivo,
por lo tanto aquí está mi solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones
de una forma gráfica,
mi punto de intersección
de ambas rectas es el punto 3, 3.
Y cuando digo sistema de ecuaciones,
a lo que me estoy refiriendo es es a varias ecuaciones,
las cuales tienen
varias incógnitas y bueno,
digo varias porque
estoy pensando en más de una,
cada una de las ecuaciones es una
construcción de sus variables y para encontrar
la solución lo que hay que hacer es encontrar
la intersección de las ecuaciones,
en los siguientes videos, lo que vamos a ver es otras
formas de resolver estos sistemas de ecuaciones
que no tengan que ver
con el método gráfico,
vamos a verlo de una manera
mucho más algebraica.